brevet pas monsieur mitterrand le
monopole du coeur vous n'avez pas le
monopole du coeur giscard
s'arrondit avec cette phase jusqu'à
s'humanise elle fait d'avoir deux coeurs
sont des pans table d'hôte orientations
politiques qui n'avaient pas le monopole
du coeur nous sommes en
1974 en plein débat de
l'entre-deux-tours à l'élection
présidentielle autour de la table deux
candidats s'affrontent monsieur françois
mitterrand pour la gauche monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing pour la droite
ils sont à un moment où c'est mitterand
qui a lancé le débat on parle de la
répartition des fruits de la croissance
économique le moment est venu monsieur
giscard d'estaing depuis longtemps où il
aurait fallu utiliser cette richesse
créée par tous afin que le plus grand
nombre vivent c'est ça je dirais c'est
presque question le tueur mon
intelligence c'est aussi une affaire de
coeur sous-entendu vous n'en avez pas
beaucoup monsieur giscard d'estaing vous
l'ancien ministre des finances c'est
vrai que giscard était caractéristique
de ces élites françaises sorties des
meilleures grandes écoles et quand on
fait de la politique on ne peut pas être
simplement un techno froid il faut que
le techno se réchauffe si je peux me
permettre l'expression et on voit bien
que giscard est agacé ça touche une
corde sensible
il met sa main sur le côté du visage il
regarde très sévèrement
françois mitterrand en lui disant au
fond en subliminal pas vous passez à et
ir mais mitterrand à sa place d'abord je
vais vous dire quelque chose je trouve
toujours choquant et blessant de
s'arroger le monopole du coeur vous
n'avez pas monsieur mitterrand le
monopole du coeur vous n'avez pas
giscard d'estaing doit refaire l'unité
dé droite et il n'a aucune envie d'être
corner risée comme l'homme des intérêts
financiers la rationalité froide etc il
veut mettre de l'humain dans le débat il
ne veut pas que françois mitterrand
confisqué l'uma à son seul profit et
giscard comme homme de droite dit à
l'homme de gauche qui mitterrand arrêtez
de monopoly le sentimental nous sommes
aussi chaud que vous nous avons autant
de coeur que vous j'ai un coeur comme le
vôtre qui bat sa cadence et qui est le
mien vous n'avez pas le monopole du
coeur il parlait pas aux français de
cette façon si les centres pour les
autres et là c'est un grand moment et
d'ailleurs jusqu'à dire à quelques
années plus tard c'est là où j'ai gagné
le second tour de l'élection de
l'élection présidentielle parce que je
suis sortie de l'image d'epinal de la
droite vous n'avez pas le monopole du
coeur une petite phrase de quelques
secondes grâce à laquelle peut être
valéry giscard d'estaing est devenu à 48
ans le plus jeune président de la vème
république
[Musique]